Großbritanniens junge Ärzte Leiden am
nationalen Gesundheitsdienst den nhls
ausgebrannt und unterbezahlt
26% lohnverlust in den letzten Jahren
knapp 16 Euro verdient ein sogenannter
Junior dr pro Stunde im ersten Jahr als
stünde er im Coffeeshop sie können nicht
mehr
[Musik]
junge Ärzte wie dr Paschen das sind
nicht nur die die gerade von der Uni
kommen es sind alle die noch keine
facharztreife haben bis dahin kann es
zehn Arbeitsjahre dauern auf
unterbesetzten Krankenhausstationen
[Musik]
ich habe so schnell gearbeitet und oft
versucht nebenbei am Schreibtisch zu
essen und diesen ganzen Papierkram zu
machen erschöpft am Ende des Tages
eine Erschöpfung die man schwer
beschreiben kann es ist so als Mann auf
vorspulen geschaltet wie
erfassti bereitet sich auf die
Nachtschicht vor ihre Karriere als
Ärztin hatte fast zeitgleich mit der
corona-pandemie begonnen sie sagt sie
kenne eigentlich nur Notstand im
Krankenhaus und seither wäre es auch
nicht besser
[Musik]
wir sind an der Front halten es
irgendwie zusammen es gab diese Moral
als covet begann und jetzt wird es immer
heikler durchzuhalten mit dieser
Arbeitsbelastung und dem fehlenden
Personal
und schließlich gehen wir ja auch mit
Patienten um
any within patience
fast die Hälfte aller Ärztinnen und
Ärzte sind Junior Doktors
und die Zustände in nhl-kliniken eine
Katastrophe für alle an schlimmen Tagen
solche Bilder soll die Öffentlichkeit
eigentlich nicht sehen wie lange wartet
ihr hier schon
seit 4 Uhr gestern Nachmittag also diese
Patientin war da schon 20 Stunden im
Krankenhaus
danielland er hat seinen Alltag mit
verdeckter Kamera gedreht denn einer
Dreh Genehmigung erteilte NHL so gut wie
nie der britische Sender Channel vor
veröffentlichte jetzt Daniels Bilder 16
eingelieferte Patienten vor der
Notaufnahme weil die Rettungsteams mit
ihren schweren Fällen auf den Fluren
warten kommen sie erst nach Stunden zum
nächsten Notfall oft viel zu spät
hunderte sterben deshalb jede Woche
heißt es mitten in einem
hochentwickelten Land
James Jackman ruft den Rettungsdienst
kurz vor Weihnachten seine Frau Hanna
hat Atemnot
sie sagten sie schicken den
Rettungswagen wir haben elf Stunden
gewartet ich konnte es nicht glauben als
sie reinkamen haben sie sich erstmal
entschuldigt für die Verspätung
im Krankenhaus dauert es weitere Stunden
bis auf die Intensivstation
Lungenentzündung und Blutvergiftung das
Antibiotikum kommt zu spät ich sagte ihr
dass ich sie liebe sie sagte das auch
[Musik]
keine halbe Minute später hatte sie
einen Herzstillstand
[Musik]
die Gewerkschaft sagt mehr als die
Hälfte der Rettungsteams hat bereits
erlebt dass Patienten sterben weil sie
zu spät kamen
[Musik]
so wächst der Druck in den Kliniken seit
Jahren auch für die jungen Ärzte
machtlos gegen dauerndes scheitern an
den Aufgaben Burnout kennen viele von
ihnen Überstunden Panikattacken
Diskriminierung im hierarchischen
Arbeitsumfeld
der stressforscher sein sei puppert hat
Tagebücher von Junior Doktoren
analysiert
das zeigt die Brutalität der
Arbeitsbedingungen im Vereinigten
Königreich sofort
es ist wichtig dass wir herausgefunden
haben dass dies eine chronische
Belastung ist und zwar für die
Arbeitstage von mehr als der Hälfte
aller Studienteilnehmer und das ist
wirklich aufschlussreich
krasse Wahrheiten über den mangelhaften
Krankenhaus Alltag quer durch pupperts
Studie die Lage geht dem
Gesundheitspersonal an die Nerven so wie
den Patienten
viele junge Ärzte wollen nur noch raus
trotz der Tradition im staatlichen
Gesundheitssystem sich dem Dienst
verpflichtet zu fühlen
dabei ist die Personalnot schon jetzt
viel zu groß die Ärztin Dr tschauderi
ist Mitglied im Junior dr Komitee in
Mittel England es heißt 40% der jüngeren
Mediziner wollen den nhls verlassen
ich habe persönlich erlebt dass es immer
schlimmer geworden ist
viele meiner engen Freunde haben das
Land verlassen und arbeiten im Ausland
weil die Arbeitsbedingungen immer mieser
werden
eine Ärztin in unserer Studie kam aus
einem Dritte Welt Land sie sagte dass
sie bedauert ins Vereinigte Königreich
gekommen zu sein wegen der hohen
Belastung sie glaubte es würde in diesem
Land hier besser sein
wenig ruhmvoll fühlt er sich an der
verantwortungsvolle medizinberuf 2019
hatte paschian mukaci den Titel Miss
England gewonnen wie viel sie in der
Unterhaltungsbranche verdienen könnte
solche Gedanken kommen ihr manchmal sie
aber will helfen Ärztin sein das kostet
jeden Tag psychische Kraft ausfallen
krank werden das quält
für Kollegen wenn eine Arbeitskraft
wegfällt und die Reihe der Patienten die
behandelt werden müssen diese
Schuldgefühle hat man dauernd
drei Tage Ärzte Streik des lässt sich
umrechnen in Patienten Leid und
Wartelisten etwa 120.000 Termine und
Operationen haben sie quer durchs Land
verschieben müssen das
Gesundheitsministerium sagt es habe vor
den nhls zu einem großartigen
Arbeitgeber zu machen die Streitenden
Ärzte fühlen sich bisher
ignoriert